thank you for staying with us guys we do
appreciate it we have one of our
favorite I mean multiple time guests now
I mean at this guy at this point he's a
regular merch would you like to
introduce our guests of course our dog
it's our homie it's the big dog uh from
Predator poachers uh Mr Gordon flowers
everybody good to see you Alex Rosen
what's up buddy what's going on man
what's up how are y'all doing great dude
you're obviously doing great you've been
killing it like everything you post is
viral dude I saw that like clip that you
posted from uh the the Jessie Smollett
dudes went viral yeah I I also have to
say uh we have to upgrade his title
International pedophile yes yes you're
International
yes we do have our since we have
we land Canada for multiple charges like
child luring and child pornography wait
there's pedophiles in Canada I wouldn't
have believed it yeah I mean look at the
prime minister
said the 10 years old there in a few in
a few years I mean there's gonna be no
more pedophiles left
yeah I mean the 10 years old because
they're not crazy you know
um dude it's one of my favorite go-to's
when he's like interviewing these guys
to like get him to get their car down
and they'll be like yeah I mean you were
talking about like you know you're
talking to a 12 year old it's not like
they were eight or something or we'd
have a whole different conversation I'd
be kicking your ass if it was an
eight-year-old buddy it was 12 years old
who hasn't
and I somehow fall for that every time
oh okay yeah yeah man I was trying to
[__] this 12 year old
I saw that when you posted where you
ruined the dude's [__] wedding day
that was hilarious God oh yes so what
was that about
like a shot like a shot like a shotgun
wedding yeah Justice yeah
I'm Emily and I'm like oh no no no it's
a different Emily and then she just
breaks down his wife hears everything
and on his first day of marriage she
just walks out on his ass and dude the
crazy part is like she I said this in
the video but she had blue hair and
tattoos and I've never had anybody with
blue hair attached to say this but her
pedo husband was so [__] up that she
said I'm gonna go to my father's house
that's how pissed off she is wow she had
a father that's insane to me
craziest part of the video what was that
was that's was that the one in St
Augustine
no this one
did he I'm sorry which one
you broke up a bit that was in Kansas
City bro America was in Kansas City to
be fair
you you catch a lot of them yeah which
is so they can they get all mixed up and
of course the Signal's breaking up
because he's out catching another pedo
and he's probably driving in those like
the areas that like you don't get to
have uh experience in New Vegas till you
get DLC you know you got to drive out
you got to try that at a Utah desert
yeah they're off to catch Joshua Graham
dude you are you are like you I mean
when's the last time you slept in your
own [__] bed man
oh man
um well it's been like four or five days
but I mean to be fair the hotel beds are
definitely better than my beds
too much amen amen I love a good hotel
I I love a good room I don't have to
clean later you know what I mean I just
leave my beer bottles stronger extreme
about
I know there was that one in Texas that
liked to [__] dogs
there's a lot of those what's with the
dog thing
and I I wish I wish it's almost like
these pedophiles have no standards
the past month
God
four or five people with the infants and
toddlers And
whatever happened it just I don't know
like like look don't get me wrong all
right when I was a kid I had some [__]
happen to me whatever uh but like like
it just if it affected me in the normal
ways I just like I'm bad with
interpersonal relationships whatever but
like whatever happened to just enjoying
a good [__] with some random chick you
know so 26 year old bartender whatever
happened to just could a 26 year old
bartender and going what a night what a
fantastic evening whatever happened to
that now it's like I want you to get
your eight-year-old sister and then I'm
gonna bring in this this [__] French
Bulldog and then you're gonna like what
are you doing man let's go [__] up
bartender no now and now the kids aren't
sexy enough they cut their dicks off to
turn them the way they want to this is
insane man no it's what it is right like
it's [__] weird it's like it's like
now the country has turned into a
Build-A-Bear for pedophiles
[Laughter]
to be out of business in a few years man
yeah I don't know how I feel about that
hey dude yeah it's five years from now
he's gonna be doing videos going like
like if I went out of business for like
because there's no more pedos left I'd
be I'd be happy but out of business
because like what they're doing is going
to be legal I'm not too happy about that
yeah I know it's it's fun it's crazy
it's [__] nuts
um this is the guy that was into dogs
right
that's our first International arrest in
Canada that's Canadian guys
this guy right yes that guy's the guy in
the dogs
Hey listen man I got a dude here about a
John Deere I really gotta get out there
I love whenever they try to blow him off
for their [__] job but he caught some
dude at Walmart one time that was funny
got some guy fired from Walmart because
he was just and like the whole time
because I really gotta get back in there
it's like his only goats I really gotta
get back in there they're gonna yell at
me yeah and I love that that's your
priority right now is man I'm gonna get
fired from my Walmart Gig if I take too
long of a break and it's like I'm
sitting here with a thick Bible stack of
messages that you had with an 11 year
old maybe priorities right now bud dude
and the thing about this guy is the lady
behind her that was our live decoy he
invited her to go into the bathroom at
work and have sex with her
dude the brazenness of it is so nuts hey
what's up girl you want to come suck my
dick at the Tractor Supply where I work
you won't go in the bathroom in the
tractor supply pull your skirt up
they clean the handicap bathroom at
three o'clock every day it clean AF yeah
so be here at three be here at 3 15.
[__] and by the way I do love the
multi-cam shoot man you you got
everything like really good now well
yeah I remember their early videos you
guys were you know there were some
growing pains and there was like you
know it's like any other like when
you're doing streaming or anything where
you go oh okay well we got [__] last
time because the signal sucked so now
they always like stream one and they got
three other ones that are just recording
and it's very nice how you guys have uh
have uh grown here yeah yeah this guy
looks like he orders food at a strip
club uh-huh he looks like he has he
looks like he has a no rag rats tattoo
yeah really [__] exactly I don't know
I don't think you can even afford to
order food at a strip club he's the guy
who's on Suboxone but says he's clean
and by the way between you and me and
the wall uh Alex you don't have to
answer this but let's be honest like the
the females that voluntarily choose to
be decoys to do this kind of [__]
they're all free yeah they're all pretty
[__] up right like you got to be a
pretty [__] you got to be pretty
[__] up to operate in this world SVG
U detectives try to go home and eat
breakfast with their daughters yeah and
they just had to solve like a [__]
cereal
look hey man when you when you go to the
women's shelters they're cheap and they
were they're willing to work
and you're like and I won't even hit you
yeah but you know you know what the
story and she lets me share this that's
why I'm gonna share it um she's a great
like real life decoy um she she's pretty
damn good but
um so with her specifically in the back
uh behind him we actually caught her
molester so that's how whoa what really
[__] that's [__] yeah so you were
kind of spot on with that bird holy [__]
for real well I don't even mean like
yeah that's wild I don't even mean like
[__] up in that sense because I mean
that that I would automatically assume
something happened to you if you're out
there I just meant [__] up in terms of
like like I couldn't picture being her
right spending hours a day being like
yeah rub my 11 year old [__] you know
what I mean and then just go on a
regular date and not just be looking at
this dude like wanting to kill here
probably also [__] cool you know what
I mean like it's just there's no way you
don't carry this [__] with you
everywhere like if I were her doing that
hours a day I'd be at Publix just
standing online going I bet that that
guy's a [__] proud but that person
probably [__] dogs like he's just
there's no way it doesn't seep into your
brain and become cynical yeah I know
like I know for sure that everybody here
in the car with me I mean this is pretty
much all we talk about like make jokes
about this type of stuff I mean he
definitely consumes your life but you
know we're happy to do it we like seeing
these [__] arrested oh yeah dude what
you're doing is and by the way man the
how quickly your [__] Rumble channel
has grown is nuts dude you already have
18 000 that's awesome man
hey man just gotta keep working hard you
know what I mean yeah
yeah I'm posting the link there for
everyone to follow in our chat yeah
everyone make sure you follow Predator
poachers they're [__] amazing
um I remember when he got that strike on
YouTube and I was like just talk to
Sarah and I told Suraj I'm like I think
you're gonna want these guys over here
yeah I don't I I think they'll be able
to pull their own weight around here you
see hey and if you're and if you're
watching from like my locals or whatever
and you're you know you're watching this
because we plugged in you know be sure
to step to revenge of this is too
because I genuinely think we wouldn't be
here right now if it wasn't for them
because they're the ones that put me on
to rumble before everything went to [__]
with YouTube and if they didn't I don't
know what I'd be doing right now so they
deserve your support as well oh man
thanks we we appreciate it but this is
what we're telling us like a rumble pay
attention see what's happening here is
two content creators are coming on each
other's show to promote each other yeah
and they're actual friends
would you say rump what do you mean by
Rumble no no we're we're we're telling
Rumble
that you mean wait you mean TP USA TV
what's wrong
you're such a [__] I love you Alex
you're hilarious
I mean look he's not wrong uh it is
funny I love Rumble because especially
now the people that got some people like
Alex are on here it kind of shocks the
audience that was there originally
sometimes where they're like what are
these guys did that guy just call that
guy a [__] yeah like wait what it's
also fun like the weird thing is like
that the tribalism's so real on Rumble
and I'm sure you've experienced this on
the Predator approaches Channel but it's
like you could catch like 20 degenerate
[__] [__] videos in a row with
Biden Kamala shirts on right but as soon
as he goes into Arkansas catches one
dude in a mega hat trying to diddle a
kid I guarantee you he gets all comments
like oh I didn't know this was Trump
bashing Channel I didn't know you had an
agenda and you're like no it's dude Vito
did that bro Vito was fighting him sorry
did you say a gender that was great that
was good but like Vito was fighting that
[__] creepy pedo [__] veto yeah
was fighting with uh Alex one day on
Twitter he's like I noticed a real
ideological Slant with what you do
you're always going after trans people
of color and I'm like bro I've been
watching Alex like obsessively for years
trust me when I tell you I have watched
him catch a lot of [__] Confederate
flag waving Margarita Like There's No
Agenda here it's whoever whoever's
replying to the [__] decoys is who
he's gonna go to but he refused but Alex
one thing refuses to go against native
people because we stole their land
native pedophiles get a pass because we
stole their land from them that's right
and all we gave him was casinos that's
Alex rosen's pledge I will not litter
and I will not go after indigenous
pedophile he won that indigenous
pedophiles
that's funny that's funny you say that
because I caught one a few days ago
being investigated by the FBI so we'll
see what happens of course you did
thanks you colonizer
that's what it is man that's that's what
it is manifest destiny uh by the way
siraj is laughing very hard on the
locals chat listening to this and he
said Rumble comments are undefeated by
the way yeah that's true that's very
true I didn't realize we were just gonna
bash Trump already dude Vito really did
that though he's like you only you only
go after trans and Lefty [__]
pedophiles and I'm like dude I've seen a
dozen videos there's a he did a video
years ago that I I my one of my favorite
things that you do by the way is the
[__] ridic your thumbnails have
gotten increasingly more ridiculous so
like he always tries to get like the
pedophile to pose on them and do like
that or like the one the one where that
one you mean no there was one where he
was in a trailer park right and the
trailer across the way had a big
Confederate flag hanging from it and you
were specifically going yeah no let's
let's talk over here though let's start
and you're the way you kept like walking
around him like you could just tell he
was trying to trick this guy into being
positioned just right so he could get
like with the [__] Confederate flag
behind him
I mean dude dude I'm like a Jewish guy
involved in pedophiles of course I know
how to direct a movie
that's that is true but thank God you
know you're a Jewish guy involved on the
other side of the pedophile
it's a nice refreshing change for once
yeah
dude
every time like I see a story someone
sends me like oh Jews are doing this
dude I'm like I'm literally I'm
literally me and Alex Steiner are
literally the only two people for
preventing the Holocaust right now
you are you're carrying it on your and
Danny polishek the three of you are
carrying it for everybody you guys are
you guys are you're the Iron Dome right
now they're gonna be they're gonna be
those three there's they're gonna be
those three rare [__] Jews you see
photographs of that have like the SS
uniform on
you know look these three are all right
man they're good guys all right all
right we can't [__] get rid of them
they're all like look you want a space
program right
[__] calm down you want to balance
the budget don't you yeah we need
accounts propaganda right I mean Jesus
[__] heads here oh hey is right my
friend dude I freaking love that we're
on here or not YouTube can we just take
a moment to appreciate that yeah bro and
the numbers have been great foreign
I mean it's [__] great you know and I
I will say like it's it's the one thing
about you know and by the way rumbled
today they're pushing out we just met we
just we just got this other people
telling us they're pushing out the chat
feature for Android which of course was
one of the biggest issues Android didn't
have the uh the chat well guess what
we're gonna have by the end of the day
it looks like everyone should be having
it so if the raw is actually in the
locals chat yeah yeah
garage moderators on live streams ASAP
along live from the rumble app ASAP I
already told oh those things have been
said but yeah say it again live from the
rumble app we definitely want to do that
the IRL stuff will be really good so you
could go live right away yeah and uh and
um moderator moderators we we I like
that we can mod but we need other people
to be able to to moderate chats also I
like how everything badges badges like
if Alex if Alex
Badges and guns no no no let's go
find one gun but here look I got one
right here do not brandish the firearm
oh [__] all right but I'm only gonna
show you you could okay he does have a
gun I'm looking at it
but anyway it's a nice holster anyway
um I got the Steven Crowder shoulder
holster
because the Kydex ones dig into my gut
anyway uh listen here Max Payne calm
down no Max paying three I'm Max Payne
three when he's got the gut and the
flowered shirt moderators for sure man
I'm 100 with you with that
um that would be great and also being
able to donate on the on the apps would
be great yeah that would be probably
yeah you know it
Faith the donation part's a really big
one so I mean please add that like ASAP
please that's my favorite you're like
hey can we get uh people to be able to
donate on Android and they're like no
Android wants too much money and I'm
like all right but like what's like 40
is zero
so I said my first goal in the third
infantata is to take out these three
Jews Rosenstein in Polish yes
every time they roll out a cool new
feature he just gets yelled at for three
more things yeah it's like hey guys
today we're gonna have uh chat features
on the Android
about that we're on our Japanese sport
what about our lives shut the door
that's really good every time Rumble
does something I knew it sir Rod's
getting like oh I guess that's great but
what about the other thing I'm mad at
and you never get to like finally bro
that's so cool it's like your wife blows
you but then you're still bitching that
dinner was cold three days ago I don't
know I mean it could have been a little
warmer like I just blew you that's
grateful splc commentator donated says
yes siraj please enable gelding for our
Jewish friends
you know what you know what my favorite
is my favorite one Rumble tweets out
something and then there's always that
one [__] so he's like oh my God but
YouTube is still so much better I just
love the platform that defends pedos and
shows drag queen cicadas so much better
than Rumble ugh it is actually true
that's a really good point because every
time we're on YouTube it was like
[__] that we we just had 12 videos
taken down from our YouTube by the way
but anyway that's it yeah just 12. but
you guys aren't as good as the global
Monopoly that had a 15-year Head Start
exactly you're not as good
uh Sarah just added gelding to his list
um expansion team you're not as good as
the Yankees in your first season what's
wrong with you hey can you let the
Jaguars get Trevor Lawrence for a couple
years before we start [__] cheating
on him guys
[__] Christ yeah he's like 17 years
old give him a break calm down
he tried to [__] him Alex Rosa would
show up to you Alex you're 100 right
it's like these people go oh YouTube
lets you do this YouTube yeah okay I get
it but YouTube also gave me a strike for
bullying Jeffrey Epstein so I mean I get
it come on man and Dan Schneider and the
thing is like all those people are like
oh yeah man I support saving the kids or
I support Free Speech but dude two
clicks of a button is just a little too
much of an inconvenience for them to
actually do anything about it man yeah
no exactly and they [__] about Rumble
but it's like literally that this is the
first platform that's come along in a
while where it actually is doing a
really good job of keeping up whereas
like I'm like you [__] you [__]
suckers don't remember the dark days of
D live oh my God and all these other
websites no I got one word for you two
syllables trovo trovo was garbage
you don't know man we're Nomads we're
gypsies okay we've traveled around we've
been all of them you're getting 30 cents
on the dollar while people are casting
spells in your chat room and you don't
even know what the [__] it means I've
been kicked off 109 platforms
and I think we can all agree right it's
the platforms it is really the
platform's fault that really is you know
what we need some sort of like final
salute platform solution I think would
really help speed things up whoa whoa
whoa I mean you come on can you really
get like six million users that quick to
a plat come on man I don't think so
listen sir Roger's just trying to get
all the Jews on the
Rumble train okay that's all it is your
luggage will get there don't worry this
this train all everyone's getting off in
Fort Myers don't worry beautiful sunny
Fort Myers
oh [__] all right so you're traveling I
know you don't like to give too much
[__] because obviously you don't want to
ruin your thing but you're basically in
a cold place
in Western Oklahoma boxing him well okay
okay
look being that like I know y'all's
audience I can't say where I am because
one of them is probably the next cash
but I'll give a little bit
[Laughter]
so we are heading to Chanhassen
Minnesota okay it's a suburb of
Minneapolis and there's a 64 year old
man who's inviting an 11 year old girl
over tonight to his old age Apartments
have sex with her old age apartment it's
a retirement community oh no yeah
oh so we're on we're on Interstate 94 we
just got out of Fargo North Dakota we're
in Minnesota now bro some of these guys
the compulsion is so crazy like don't
invite them to their job or they'll
invite them to like like an apartment
where they have a roommate and I'm like
how are you gonna explain any of this
right yeah you know what I mean when I
had roommates I didn't even like like
bring in a regular [__] over because
you're like ah you're gonna have to meet
my roommate and he's a douchebag like
it's just to be fair merch has never
brought a regular [__] well you know a
regular [__] for me they're one of
those words yeah you know half a shaved
head Hello Kitty tattoo whatever look
Alex you say this about me I might date
some [__] up girls but at least he's
never gonna show up to my house because
I date the ones where I didn't do any of
the damage no you came in you already
came in with smoke and water damage that
ain't me you know what I mean I bought
you gently used never look at the Carfax
of any Martius exes they're not the best
no no no they're not the best car fast
yeah I like a certified pre-owned [__]
yeah you get a better value I mean that
we just have a we have we have a
recently divorced blue hair [__] who
just you know left one of our predators
yeah easy pickets I don't go that route
with it what I don't go that route with
it yeah if they're the really crazy
Lefty ones I don't know God no blue hair
is a weird way you know what you don't
want to [__] a vaccinated chick ah not
unless she's gonna let me get life
insurance on her only of the vaccination
only for the vaccination is for HPV
but I'm telling you man that's the way
to go get you a vaccinated [__] who's
overweight marry her take out some life
insurance and just wait oh you have your
plan you have your plan and that's it
Alex hold you again man I know I always
ask
well it was my 23rd birthday yesterday
oh happy birthday 23 years old and the
[__] you're doing is awesome dude that's
I mean that's [__] nuts yeah you're
already beating all the other guys and
it's sad like even the other guys who
have good channels that do what you do
like that are amusing or whatever they
just don't emphasize it's not enough on
the catching them part it's always like
hey let's just shout him down at a
Walmart and we'll just all move on and
by the way can I say your fan you talk
about our fans your fans are awesome I
mean they're [__] crazy like ours I
think this is a huge crossover but your
fans are like loyal dude like I love
when they show I love when they
literally send him fried pickles yes yes
somebody be like yo I recognize that
apartment complex like Uber Eats drivers
will be rolling up with a Buffalo Wild
Wings bag and he's like all right thanks
man
like I mean literally yesterday we had
we had a grandma of four uh drive an
hour and 20 minutes just to give us a
tray of your you get the tray of
desserts
desserts that's [__] awesome
scotch or whatever forgot what they were
called she brought us like a whole tray
of like pastries like drove an hour and
20 minutes into the middle of nowhere
North Dakota to do it yeah I mean that's
pretty much like they're the only Vice
in that crew too trust me I tried to get
him drinking one night you can't yeah I
was like hey let's oh look at that there
it is that's awesome thank you Valerie
dude that's so good after Valerie
yeah we um like yeah when I hung out
with them I was like hey come on let's
get some drinks boys and they were like
no we just like snacks Grandma
unfortunately there she is Grandma
Four's in the chat that's me there she
is
dude you're awesome that's [__]
awesome I want cookies and cakes
the first time that we met Alex he was
wearing like a Hillary what was it a
Hillary shirt because you know protect
trans protect trans kids shirt and we
were eating at this really nice
steakhouse in Texas it was so funny it
was so [__] funny
[Laughter]
let's all do a show together at the
rumble Studio next time you're in town
we're locals either one or locals too
yeah they haven't invited either one the
locals and uh the the rumble ones in uh
Longboat yeah so next time you're down
either would they let you guys go in any
time yeah yeah so Raj already said 100
well I mean we probably can't just wait
I'm sure if we let him know with a
couple days notice yeah they'll let us
use this that'll be fun man we're trying
to use it we're trying to find any
excuse to use it because let's do it
that'll be fun
can you can you like uh y'all hear me
yeah yeah
okay y'all imagine like how just cool
that is that you guys can go to the
rumble studio and just do it I mean I
mean like the people watching like have
no idea how evil YouTube was to us I
think they do but it's just how
refreshing this all feels to us that
like you guys just get to go to the
rumble studio and that we have like a
direct line to the people that work that
route let's [__] say it but by the
way it's Horizon assassin yes yes come
through so see what I mean we're welcome
but but you know what I was talking was
talking to Suraj and I were talking to
Raj about the other day it's like
YouTube Feels Like YouTube Buck breaks
you because you've been there so long
and even today it kind of like today I
was you know doing day when there was
some sort of glitch on Rumble and it
basically like all the shows were
showing like zero people watching right
and I just messaged her rods I'm like
hey man what's going on here but he's
like nah man it's a sight wide thing
they're working on it and he goes don't
worry about it it's not you and I'm like
and it's immediately like God you're
right the first thing you think is like
did I do something wrong again is
YouTube coming for me yeah and you're
like no that doesn't happen over here
like okay cool okay cool yeah
relationships when like his woman start
freaking out and he needs to like let
him know that you know they're good now
or what now when a woman is freaking out
Mercy's on his phone calling on Uber
yeah so it's not
generally that or I'm like paying out a
tab and apologizing to the bar staff
yeah and being like I'm really sorry
about this I've said that more times in
my life than I'd like to admit on behalf
of a girlfriend
um guys I'm really sorry I'm really
sorry about this and by the way for
those wondering we're reading those
donations from they're from our locals
revenge of assist.locals.com Hit the
join button all right the locals hype
make sure you follow our Channel too
we're trying to get that 15K hype yeah
and I'm putting I'm putting I've been
putting the link for predator poachers
in there over and over again uh Zen
Reiner with Zen Reiner Zen Reiner then
Reiner with a ten dollar five dollar
hype train did Zuma get that black guy
from being allergic to the fried pickles
you offered him oh you implying the uh
uh Chad Zuma Chad zumac he's a look he's
just that's the proper answer when his
name is brought up exactly he's just an
unfunny comedian he's not an actual
Predator a pedo that I know no no he's
good he's good uh well I mean I mean I
don't know I don't know I'm not you
never say any definitive statements but
you know uh nothing that I know of uh
if Rumble gets keeps up the great work
they'll take over and leave YouTube in
the dust that's not going to happen
because the thing is is that Rumble
might do great but YouTube is propped up
YouTube wasn't making money for the
longest time it's a propaganda it's a
propaganda program is what it is yeah it
still operates 100 is man and like when
people when people came to me and were
like oh
oh they're just they're just removing a
predator catching because it's not a
good business to have it on actually it
was great business for them to have it
on you know just removing it because
business decisions and money though they
care about money out no YouTube doesn't
care about money they care it's exactly
a propaganda piece they don't give a
[__] about a profit they're too big to
fail it's always been a loss leader for
for yes for alphabet Inc and it's always
been alphabet pumps money in there
because they can control the culture
controlling the culture is way more
valuable than turning a profit so I just
want to work I want to work somewhere
where I'm here to make money are you
here to make money you know and that's
it
yeah like dude Susan with jiki doesn't
matter to her if she gets paid 30
million or 35 million she cares about
making sure kids are looking at drag
queens and all that stupid [__] I mean
that's the thing like once they have all
this type of money does it like yeah it
doesn't matter to them but pushing the
culture I agree
I think uh besides we got that it's not
Susan anymore we got that uh the
Whatchamacallit the engine guy oh yeah
yeah
did uh did you see that DeSantis is
taking that liquor license away from the
place that had the direct show he's
taking the liquor license away well he
told him not to do it and they did it I
think he's taking it so I mean it wasn't
like he pulled it wasn't like he decided
to do it out of the blue they got a
letter from the governor and he said if
you're going to serve alcohol and twerk
on little kids we're pulling your
[__] liquor license make no mistake
about it they held the show and he
showed up and took their [__] liquor
license what's the problem we're gonna
spin that though bro dude oh dude
where's boots and his wife wears gloves
look at those [__] degenerates I mean
yeah here's a picture of Rhonda Sanders
drinking so he's pulling all the liquor
for himself guys obviously uh yeah she's
so annoying that's I can't wait until
she starts accusing him of like being a
drunk because he has a beer at the Super
Bowl and we're gonna be like yeah you're
making Florida like him more you don't
understand how Floridians you don't
think
the State of Florida has revoked its
liquor license for hosting a drag queen
performance where kids were present
violating existing state law and local
10 live down in Miami with a sudden
Crackdown Cody
and Calvin the DeSantis Administration
is this a [__] I feel bad for Cody
Weedle poor guy little little man is
saying that the Hyatt he looks like an
unfinished zielinski clone
come in the name of this
hey that's right next one you know what
hear me out next Predator approach
Ukraine
um
I'm telling you dude I have all my
content for the next two years in
Ukraine yep yep highly sexualize Drag
Queen performance with children present
and they say that violates existing
Florida statute well no they don't say
that it does it does violate existing
foreign the Florida Department of
Business and Professional Regulation
moving to suspend the liquor license of
the Hyatt Regency in downtown Miami
it's not a little bar it's one of the
main hotels the Hyatt Regency there
which is [__] day man he got you got
warned so easy to think all these people
that are mad at this we're cheering them
on when people were losing their liquor
licenses because they were people
wearing masks or one social distance
they were like oh yeah how great yeah
the government should take them away but
now when this is like overstep what an
overstep what's unreasonable about that
though if I pull a key out right and I
go by Alex's car and I go I'm gonna key
your car and you go if you do that I'm
going to punch you in the face and then
I just do it anyway like what would I
what would I expect other than to get my
[__] face punched oh you clearly
stated what the penalties were gonna be
here yeah and all the headlines are like
oh they go to revoke because it was a
drag show they never mentioned for kids
man they're so sick yeah that's a good
that's another good point that they they
under they underplay what what it was
like it's not just because it was a drag
show it was a drag show with children
dude I lived in South Tampa and Ybor
City for years and I never had a problem
with all the gay bar you know there was
a plenty of drag shows going on there
was no kids around nobody cared it was
never offensive to anybody until you
started being like hey let's let's bro
let's twerk on eight-year-olds yeah yeah
do whatever you want if you're an adult
of its League I don't give a [__] you
know and then they're like I really
don't know but you'll bring your kid to
a Hooters and I'm like yeah because the
Hooters isn't [__] the Hooters girl
isn't rubbing her clam all over my
eight-year-old he's just asking them
what kind of [__] boneless wings he
wants you know
actually pulled their license for
hosting a drag show I'd absolutely vote
for him even more I mean yeah yeah
they're like you they you just hate gay
people and I'm like listen if I found
out that a 10 year old boy was in a
regular strip club and they were just
like surfing and liquor and letting him
get lap dances I would go I think we're
all in agreement that we need to shut
that club down I don't think that club
needs to be it's not a gay thing it's
like wait you just had this kid hanging
out in this [__] in this strip club
drinking booze that's pretty bad uh
speaking of the key thing this is uh
this is you mentioned the key thing I
wanted to show you guys are going to
know this is [__] have you seen have
you have you seen Street Justice the
street Justice that happens here watch
so this guy is King this dude's Mercedes
right is what you're looking at
that doesn't exude the whole car this
king is so expensive so this guy comes
and
beats the [__] out of him
knocks him out hold on then he then he
gets his baton and
he's out
he is out that's that what that's called
the street Justice
why he was mad let's see the car
here you go
why did he do it
because it's Ohio
it's Ohio bro I don't understand the the
Earth like I remember when I was a
teenager like just wanting to break [__]
and be a little dick but like adults
that just have this urge it's like oh
that's nice I want to ruin that
with the urges yeah it's a socioeconomic
thing man that's literally all it is but
even when I didn't have [__] I didn't
look at your [__] and go look I'm gonna
ruin this first no dude it's all a
socioeconomic thing I mean if we just if
we just gave them five million dollars
everything would be fixed you you
understand that right well we don't have
enough we have to give it all the
Ukraine oh my God that's right so San
Francisco money for them what was it San
Francisco was with five million dollars
for every black resident yeah oh
absolutely because when they steal money
the first thing they do is absolutely
invest in stocks and you know if I put
options all that stuff it's not like
they buy shoes or anything like that so
giving them five million I mean it's
just gonna fix everything yeah that'll
be gone in a week it's [__] yeah
remember that guy remember the guy
recently he was like oh yeah you know
maybe you need to give us reparations so
our children stop breaking in your
liquor stores it's not just stealing
your jewelry and [__] it's like wait
what are you threatening come on I'm
doubling up if I go to San Francisco if
you're a black [__] you get double
money you get the reparations money and
you get the training money and you
legally get to steal up to a thousand
and you can steal up two thousand
dollars you have to use your money
that's pretty dope all right hear me out
does anyone have any shoe polish I have
an idea I have a wig already we can make
some money here okay [__] I got a
basketball back there too bro let's go
shoe polish on your face dribble in a
basketball they'll never see through the
disguise
going and be like hey man I have when I
get my reparations at man I have a mask
so I'm just no I do I have an old man
black old black bro I would give
anything for you to wear that mask and
go to throw and try to apply for that
[__] [__]
dude I'm sure that'd be so funny I would
[__] die I would [__] die to see
Royce go in that [__] office and be
like I would like my reparations please
there you go that's not racist at all
this is almost as it's almost as bad as
Owen Benjamin's happy Merchant mask no
it's not it's an old man I'm not doing a
voice if I do the voice it'd be a
problem but I'm not doing a voice
oh my God I will not to avoid I refuse
I get it because also I can't breathe
okay
well if you keep using props on this
show I'm gonna put my knee in your back
so
um oh black men are trained
I'm uh I I'm I'm doing a show now with a
guy who's 50 mostly Foley work at this
point it's mostly just oh [__] it's hair
got hair on me
that was not blackface that was a mask
I'm allowed to wear a mask no but Owen's
been good he's been spiraling and
fighting and you know yelling at his
prominent fans again and he's screaming
about the Holy Trinity and you know just
just good wholesome Christian stuff
oh that would have been cool [__] are
you gonna get it you should go get a
picture of the Cup Foods like at the
Statue
wait they put a statue of him there
didn't they I thought they did they did
the George Floyd statue and they renamed
the road I believe yeah there's a whole
Plaza yeah yeah where the Cup Foods is
you could go in and get yourself go to
Cup Foods go to Cup Foods and take a
picture of yourself buying a banana
oh my God
dude yeah I actually want to go to the
place where it happened man I go there
and get a video of him doing the Banana
Dance
I'm just gonna give him a piece of paper
20s and try to pay for something see
what happens here you go 120 bill it's
that bad shitty note notebook paper too
where it has like the it has all the
things from the top still hanging off
has anybody ever done that has anybody
ever made like novelty George Floyd
twenty dollar bills
is that what I have a feeling those
would sell
yeah dude I'm gonna do that I can do
that prank tonight all right we'll see I
mean I'm literally gonna do it now that
you know what we said it could you
imagine him over [__] around people
with Cup Foods like what are they doing
nothing
not call the police that's for sure
let me check I was told to update the
rumble app let's see
I updated the rumble app okay this phone
crash and no it's okay I have a virus um
no go to live chat oh [__]
live chat in the rumble all right on
Android yeah bro Android there it is
there it is can you donate that's the
most important thing no not yet oh oh
yeah I know I know uh anti-semitic
attacks I was gonna say bro leave it to
the Jew to say can I get the money
though that's the most important thing
I think I believe okay
I believe what I'm trying to convey is
that for me what is of the most
Paramount concern
is being able to receive money
dude I hope the Ada writes an article
talking about how they added the live
chat before the Donate option to talk
about how that's an attack on our
democracy
it is though how do we expect poor Alan
dershowitz to make money if he can't
accept money on Rumble
Epstein's not allowed it Epstein doesn't
have them on retainer anymore he's got
to keep that overhead
uh we got a ten dollar tip how many of
these can I get for five mil okay so he
say so he puts it to 303 Nasheed in the
chat posted a picture of Newport
sweatpants how many of these can I buy
for five million
wait Did they really make Newport
sweatpants I kind of want them real
Tariq Nasheed says Omar Mateen should
have waited five more years ten dollars
I unironically want the Newport
sweatpants
yeah Jesus Christ
um [__] [__] we've come we're coming up
to the end of this hey Alex what are we
plugging man
all right plug my Rumble it's predator's
on Rumble that's proud
predator and then posters
p-o-a-c-h-e-r-s
um if you want to see Predators get
caught and arrested and very sick [__]
get caught um yeah go ahead and head on
over to their sub to us and uh look if
you're coming from my channel go ahead
step to revenge of assists they are the
funniest show
and I watch them the most out of I mean
they're pretty much the only thing I
watch on the internet anymore I'm too
busy to watch anything else but I always
make time for them and uh yeah you guys
are awesome and uh these are the best
people online right here that I'm
talking to so second class Predator
poachers are the best dude number one
we'll take number two that's fair but
it's true and I will give him credit he
does you know some people always go oh I
love the show guys like you don't
[__] watch her shut up I will I will
ask you voucher for Alex because he'll
text me in the middle of the night yeah
me too and be like dude I'm a little
like behind three days or so but did
such and such happen like yeah and it'll
be some [__] from last Thursday and I'm
like oh yeah yeah man well he's like
he'll actually like ask a follower yeah
I'm days behind sorry man but I'm on the
road I was just watching I'm like man he
does watch himself so mad love to
Predator poachers uh and also I'm
assuming it's Predator
poachers.locals.com right it's probably
the same yeah but hey man if we get
everybody subbing to our Rumble you know
the rest will take care of itself yes
worried about Rumble guys and uh yeah
thank you all for being here so hey dude
thank you thank you for being on man I
know you're you you you you you're
saving the world management you are
legit one of my favorite people man and
I'm glad we uh you know crossed paths in
the last couple hell yeah
all right dude what happened
we were complimenting you yeah so it's
fine you missed it okay I'm not gonna
repeat myself we said what a cutie pie
we said we were super you're a cutie pie
is what we said
well that was merch that said it not me
also to quote orc from uh uh uh osw when
uh you know the reason I won't repeat
the compliment is I don't like
repetition I don't like repetition I
don't like all right oh God
hey Alex thank you so much man you're
welcome on of course anytime and when
next time we're down here we're going to
the rumble Studio local Studio doing the
show
wow I can't wait to watch all right
later man take it easy man he [__]
rules Alex is the [__] man he's the
man he actually a good reception this
time